Hi, I'm Arun Pradeep from CSE department. I am
currently pursuing third year of engineering in Panimadar Engineering College and
recently I am working on a project which is a chatbot application.
Whereas user can upload all kind of PDF Excel sheets
and even the audio files like dot MP3 extension
fields which is a MP3 files. So all these files can be
uploaded by the user and most of the
features are that implemented in this project are already
inside GPT except the one feature which is getting the
transcript from an audio file and asking question to that audio file.
So the user can upload all kind of PDF Excel sheets and as
well as the audio files and he can ask anything about it.
So the main reason of why we need to why someone need to
use the application is it reduces the time consumption.
The user can ask any question to the PDF,
upload a document and get a significant as well as the
faster response from that particular PDF.
Here the tech stack I used are React as a front end and for backend
I go for Python which is REST API and fast API
and and here also I used some of the APIs
which is open source LLM such as GPT 2.0
and also for the transcription of an audio file here that I used
Assembly AI to transcript the files. The user
can access all kind of PDF content that he uploaded
and ask any kind of questions based on the PDF and the LLM
answer only to the particular question he asked if and only if the
content was actually present in the PDF. This is the project I am working
on and this is here I'm finished the introduction.